cornado able to carry the puck to the line
and give it to hanman back to Coronado tip
but he settles it down works it in deep
plays it in front off the goer ainger
bounces back to the line gilber with a shot
that goes wide here's cornado tries the W
out chi on goal bu back to Hanah Hanah to the
circle in front Sharon Mage can't get a clean
rebound poke One play back across to cadri
to the line tanon cadri T shoots deflected
zerry scores Conor Jerry and his first NHL
game gets a goal that makes it one nothing
Calgary they are all over the Stars cadri gets a
puck back to tanv he gets a return pass now tanv
just throws it in front there's Sharon goich
right in front the puck hits somebody in front
goes to Zer and he's right where he needs to
be in front of the net off his body and Taps
it in first first taken away by Steel makes
play to the line but it's intercepted there
momentarily Anyway by Greer taken back by the
Stars here's steel trying to get it front Jam
to on goal markstrom down able to keep it out
with that P one more time for weager on the
pass to Hanan it goes right to Wyatt Johnston hin
enjoins the watch Johnson in front shot by Hast
going to turn it away Marr Johnston try to jam
it off pinball around finally settled down and
a penalty coming up to Calgary on put it all the
way down the ice that was the thing that really
stood out to me when I was doing my research Rick
about Dallas their power play their numbers with
that Talent that's very very low b side of the
goal Robertson Jabs it on goal and it's turned
away Jordan o Bank pass picked off Harley back
the other way trying to get around ultral touch
in deep got a weak shot away marks him able to
keep that right foot on the post and make the
save then he covers up the rebound with 341 left
under pressure pushed to the boards by hackin paw
cleaned up by Lindell who puts it around all the
way down the ice Midway through the power play as
we hit the final minute of play arch had to wait
because the puck was in the no go Zone and they
score shorthanded hint able to set up Ben and
that was an awkward play for Mark and he gets
caught and a short Ed goal by the Stars ties this
up at one well if Jacob markson was going to go
he should have gone before the puck crossed the
goal line and just take the look at hints when
he recognizes that Mark can't go now he turns on
the Jets right here and then he just quickly spots
Ben and Ben's got those great hands so there is a
tiny bit of hesitation by markstrom as you know he
can't play that puck in that area and so he had
to have gone out and played the puck before it
crossed the goal line kept Alive by weager with
a good play at the Blue Line 10 seconds left in
the period here's Hanahan xer mapon with a the
shot and AER is able to make the save on a setup
by the rookie and and he takes a shot without
looking but tinger is in perfect position backin
the faceoff Circle against hel landria the Flames
win it xeri gets the punt settles it down makes
a pass to wager with a shot at a pass Byers the
horn sounds and period one comes to an end so and
all the guys that I was partnered with throughout
my career congratulations it's coming up Allstar
Weekend uh you're going to be there on the 9th
of November to the rink and uh you know we got
to know Jane and the family Amelia was born and
just steal by Coleman here's backin and a pat save
by ottinger weager shoots and that's stopped
by tinger S all the way Harley HS the puck to
the corner but it's stolen by L with a nice play
and now a pass by maai [Applause] [Music] scores
fantastic shift early in the second pays off
and the Flames up 2 one he's been great so far
four shots on goal already look at the work
down low Harley turns it over and the flame
just don't give up on it get the puck right the
slot to M japani but that's a young mistake or a
mistake by a young player in Harley he had the
puck right along the boards and weager gets it
right in front to M japani boy steel getss it
to delandria he'll work it in with Craig Smith
delandria swings in wide on weager tie delandria
puts it behind the net Anderson hassle by Smith
and there's steel trying to tuck it in the wrap
around on the backhead pass to hunt and he'll
carry up gain Center and Chip it in Flames will
change after the icing call Coleman the low man
up in the for CH Joel pavelski to Center hon
full strike stops drops it off there's a shot
they score off a stick Robertson able to put
it in it hit weager stick it went flying and
the puck Finds Its way past markstrom and we're
all tied up a two and right from their own Zone
watch this pass right up the middle right there
pavelski the hints and he's just going to set
it up for Robertson and unfortunately for Jacob
marstrom watch the release when Robertson gets
it and the puck is going to go off the Stick of
weager right there and then it gives marks from
all sorts of problems and sneaks five ball
those are so tricky even though it's not a
hard shot Robertson looking for a second of the
period hits hinan here's Robertson again plays
it in front great save markstrom absolutely robs
Joe pavelski you can't believe it but we have to
talk about this save once again there's pavelski
right from his spot s plays the puck down low
it's chipped away not out though kept it in for a
moment now Ben able to settle it down with a pass
all the way across here's lung push into the Zone
drops it off the donov cuts to the middle of the
scores top corner and the stars have their first
lead as dadonov makes it 3-2 they're worried about
the speed of the stars and they're just easily
entering the Zone Dallas now watch how far the
Flames defense sink in and then that's a screen
the donov uses T up nicely is a screen just works
his way into the front of the net and if you're
going to give them that much time and space they
are going to find openings that team is too
talented Su circles L nette can't get a pass
can but gets some help from Marchman he clears
s's pass to flex bounces through over to Duan
Duan pled it front they score marshman able
to tuck it in with 10.7 left and it's 42 down
Dallas well Dallas uses her skill marks and watch
this Puck come up in the air and then it's going
to go right through the legs of Hanahan right
there to duain who's been really good today
throws a backhand pass in front to Marchman but
this is a Play Noah Hanahan knows he needs to make
it's a bad mistake a bit of a pick by Marksman not
allowing Hanan back in but that's a we've talked
about this many times often when you're playing
well and winning You'll Play A Couple of bad games
before you start losing and I think the reverse
is true too when you're in a slump it takes lle
pressure to the corner by Suter Puck comes back
to the point good job by weager to keep the play
on side here's weager again shoots scores weager
on the power play and it's a one goal [Applause]
game well I talked about McKenzie weager in
the second period timely goal by McKenzie
weager and the Flames just we're going
to keep this Puck alive and watch weer
get open right here and there's LOL skating
in front of hinger and I believe that's all
he needed for the screen let's see if it hits
something or somebody oh it definitely hits
oh yes it hits right off his right hand on
the bottom stick there delandria first and
then off the arm of Lindell still nursing
a one goal lead flames have Chi away with
that power play goal by weager they look to
tie it up here here's a WRA out attempt by
hubero turned away by AER that taken away by
weager but only 5 seconds left time winding
down long shot from Center stopped and the
Flames run out of time 47 shots on goal